[Music]
this is
the ramsay show you can be intentional
about your character
you can have money and a career you are
the hero
in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car
rental studio this is the ramsay show
where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life
and your money i'm christy wright i'm a
business coach
author and speaker and i'm joined today
by one of my good friends
number one best-selling author and host
of the ken coleman show
ken coleman himself what is happening
chris
it's friday it's friday which is fun i
love hosting on fridays i just
i just feel a little extra feisty and
excited about the weekend
so this is gonna be fun it's gonna be a
fun show today i wanna warn everybody
when you've got some
extra feisty that means it's gonna be
really really good so if you've been
wanting to get a question answered by
christy today's the day
we got some extra feist you just never
know okay you never know what's
what's going to happen on this show
listen aaa 825-5225
ken and i are here for you we are taking
your calls
answering your questions of course we're
always taking
your money questions ken is an expert
on career and purpose let's take those
calls you got a call
you didn't get into his show calling in
his show call us here we'll answer it
live
on air as for me i love helping you with
business you all know i
love all things business side business
small business
uh have my book business boutique so we
can always take your business calls
but i'm currently in a theme of talking
about a different topic
which is right here balance right here
here it is take back your time the guy's
down in the control room look at that
look at that that baby is hot
so hot i should have put some gloves on
it's available for pre-sale take back
your time the guilt-free guide to life
balance and if anybody understands this
it's you i mean
uh you are a fantastic personality
you've got three kids
uh a husband who's a very successful
professional
i mean you got a lot of plates spinning
so why did you write this
you know i wrote the book i needed ken
is this what we all do always works
but it's so funny you say that because
this book i wrote this book
um over a year ago you know with the
whole process and stuff but i feel like
i'm in a season where i'm living this
out
living out my own principles in a whole
new level because i don't i think you
know this
but i started seminary a few weeks ago
you didn't know that so just add that
very impressive add that to the schedule
in terms of managing your time but
here's what's interesting i think that
whether or not you have little kids
older kids
no kids male or female working outside
the home inside out
we all have this sense that things
aren't right
that we're failing that we don't have
enough time that we're out of balance
and so
when i started going down this path
because i've been talking about this for
over a decade speaking at companies and
stuff on this topic
i wanted to talk about it in a new way i
wanted to get beneath the surface of the
calendar
and the schedule and the time management
apps and productivity tips
and talk about why we feel that way in
the first place and let's solve it
there so that we can fix the root cause
and then oh by the way that will fix our
calendar so
as ken said take back your time the
guilt-free guide to life balance is
available for pre-sale
when you get your copy in pre-sale you
get the e-book free the audiobook free a
ticket to my event in september free
and uh and a bunch of goodies so get
your
pre-order copy and it will be mailed to
you september so
14. let's take some of those calls too
you know obviously everything we
mentioned and christy and i
both of us love to we love to tag team
the calls not just on the money stuff
but also hey
i i think i've got this i want to do
this how do i best go about it what's
next for me what's my next step
so we're gonna uncover the emotional as
well as the practical
around living on purpose whether it's
starting that side hustle or making the
change or some of you
you're killing it and you just feel like
the water is rising and chrissy can help
there so
we really want to open it up because we
know there's so many of you out there
who are getting after it
and this topic this book um is so
relevant so hey don't be afraid to call
in
christy we know we do this on the ken
coleman show a lot and i want to mention
it some of you
are hurting today and you need to talk
to christy on this particular topic or
us
on finances or or work getting that
bigger shelf whatever it is
and because it's the second largest show
in the world
on radio you're feeling like i don't
know well we'll change your name
change your location okay kelly will do
that because we want you to call in
and feel like you can be vulnerable and
safe with christy and i yeah but we'll
change your name you'll change your
location if you've got a sticky
situation
yeah you have that safety so i just want
to mention that first no that's good
triple eight eight two five
five two two five ken i actually have a
question for you as we as we kick off
this
show together today and i think this is
gonna be fun because
i often get questions about um
where do i find my business idea i want
to start a business i want to do
something next and i know you get
similar calls maybe not specific to
business but what's my next step
how do i know i've got this itch let's
put it that way i've got this itch to do
something i'm feeling
um stagnant there's nowhere really for
me to grow in my company
what's next for me i'm curious when you
get these calls how you advise people
because i know you get them
and there's a lot of different options
for that next path so let's just start
there as we kind of kick this off and
maybe we'll get some calls about
about career inside business and what
the next step is so when somebody calls
in and says i've got an
itch i know that there are some ideas
behind the itch but a lot of times
people will call and they'll present and
say i really don't have any idea
and i've gotten to the point now
approaching 5 000 callers
where i know that's not true so the
first thing i'm going to say is that's
not true
you have an idea i know you do like the
very fact that you go
i know i'm not supposed to do this means
that your brain and your heart at some
point have connected
and there's something that you're
thinking of thinking about and so i want
to dive into that and we begin to say
okay what's behind the itch
and so there's an idea it may not be a
well flushed out idea
it may just be i kind of want to work
with
blank and when we can begin to get there
now we want to dive deeper and christie
you know my methodology that helps
people with clarity
and then the confidence to step out and
that is okay let's look at this idea
do what talent would you need what
skills hard skill soft skills would you
need
to be able to pull this off so they'll
tell me and then we'll walk through it
okay great because talent folks
that's the tools i mean that's your tool
belt so you look at your hard skills
soft skills so soft skills people skills
hard skills something that you're
physically doing or
uh mentally doing it's a skill think of
those as the tools you'll use to do the
work
that you love now you've got to say okay
do you what do you love about this idea
what about that idea
what work involved task function role
is connected to this idea and they begin
to identify actual work
okay so maybe for somebody who wants to
be a teacher they go i love
communicating i love connecting
and i love instructing and helping
people with the light bulb
and in the conference to do something
with the light bulb whatever it is okay
so then we identify the work itself
i love this idea of the work or i love
the work i've done this work before i
love it
and then the third piece christy is
missional result so
all work creates results
so what results do you want to put into
the world what
what contribution you want to make with
your work that's mission
so talent is what i do best passion is
what i love to do most
and mission are the results that i want
to produce when those
three indicators get in alignment
your professional purpose statement is
essentially filled out i use what i do
best
to do work i love to produce results
that matter to me
so whether that is an entrepreneurial
venture or a career path working for
somebody else
that's how you get clear and as you know
clarity leads to confidence
and confidence leads to courage and
that's how you step
out it's so good it's so good it's so
practical too because people need these
steps because there's people listening
right now that have an idea
and i love that you dig it out of me you
say no you have it what is it
yeah that's confirmation that's right
that's it it's good it's good
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more
[Music]
[Music]
verses
[Music]
i'm christy wright sitting in with me
today is ken coleman my good friend
and ramsay personality number one
best-selling author host of the ken
coleman show
which is available every weekday on
siriusxm your local radio station and
wherever
you listen to podcasts we are here
for you we're taking your calls triple
eight eight two five
five two two five of course we are
always ready to answer your money
questions
whether that's questions about what to
pay off next how to get out of debt
quicker
you know something that we really love
to talk about is how to help you earn
extra money
yes to pay off that debt maybe you need
a bigger shovel you're in baby step two
and you're like gosh i
feel like i'm never gonna get out of
debt well i love that we can talk about
side businesses part-time jobs getting
your income
up getting promoted hello promoted
and i gotta tell you you're the queen
your business boutique program your
coaching program i mean if you
if you've always had this idea of a side
hustle and you feel like you got to go
work a
second or third job to get out of debt
or maybe to fund
uh getting qualified to move up and
you're going i don't know
give christy a call i promise you it's
not as complex or scary as you think so
you know many times working for yourself
christy is a better option
than going to work for somebody else in
a second or third job let's just talk
about a specific example real quick and
then we've got some calls coming in so i
want to go to the phones
uh let me tell you ken my mom built this
cute little ice cream truck stand
thing okay she built tiny houses for fun
in her retirement it's a whole thing i
realize that's not normal people
really it's adorable and hilarious i
mean is she selling them
no no this is just for herself just for
fun she donates the tiny houses to the
homeless like it's
she's she's killer she's amazing i knew
she could bake i didn't know she could
build and i nor did i didn't either nor
did i so you like go over their house
and like you hear a power saw in the
backyard you walk around you're like mom
yes and she's got a tool belt on yes yes
okay
so she builds are you ready for this she
builds this ice cream truck
on a trailer that she brings over to my
house and we set up a little ice cream
stand in the neighborhood that carter's
going to run because carter's dream
when he grows up is to be an ice cream
man awesome so
so i think i picture this saturday i put
it out on facebook in our neighborhood
and i said hey we're going to do a
little ice cream stand
you know so cute sure i'm picturing that
i'm gonna sit in a lawn chair
my son's gonna make two dollars this is
a great business lesson and we're all
done right like it was a fun action sure
sure
ken coleman oh no he made 200
in like two hours he doesn't even know
what two hundred dollars is
that's phenomenal no but i thought what
was he doing the scooping and everything
well it was like it was like ice cream
sandwiches we gotta keep it simple for a
six-year-old
you know i was gonna say it's impressive
but the point is yeah
the money you can make when you start a
side business or small business he's
six years two hundred dollars in two
hours you said
yes yes yeah and i'll bet and people are
like uh when is carter gonna be back uh
i get asked every time i walk through
the neighborhood when is the carter
so if you and matt sat down and said
okay well let's see let's come up with a
skill
what's our what's our plan for the ice
cream shop uh he has no concept of what
does this even mean does he have a name
it's carter's ice cream truck it's real
creative but listen the point is the
point is
you can make a lot of money when you do
your own thing the sky is the limit
especially if you're trying to get out
of debt yes you can take a part-time job
you also could have an ice cream truck
and be getting out of debt
me carter's ice cream ice cream truck
ought to show up at ramsey solutions
next friday and he'll make two greens we
would not even have the inventory for
that
that's that's so true all right let's go
to the phones we've got cynthia in
mobile alabama hey cynthia how are you
hi how are you good how can ken and i
help
well first of all thank you guys for the
show and thank you guys for
coming to work to do this line of
business today so ask
a few questions let's try to piggyback
on each other
first of all to you well to ken
uh you gave me some advice about six
months ago he hasn't said he'll say he
hesitated
fine just pull the trigger i'll let the
day job go you did so that was
the grand
so fill us in what did you you quit the
day job to do what
well i had another thing going that i've
been doing for the last 20 years a plus
that i absolutely love and that's been
another signing agent
which goes out to you know a person's
home to close
these real estate bills and the market
is absolutely phenomenal
i i can't even buy time to do out of
work okay
so absolutely not that but i'm just
trying to be realistic and think
okay so what can i pick it back off this
so if
everything is not selling then what's
going to be the backdrop
the opposite of this to study now
to nudge myself when sales sort of
dissipate and
go to other direction i guess the real
market would go up and so i'm just
trying to think what along that line
can i do to be prepared
yeah so you're saying what's next for
you yes
definitely i have an idea that i want to
do
i think it would be so phenomenal to
work with our mama bear
and do these real kids but people don't
want to address the issue
they don't want to talk about the
subject and i just figured i can cater
it to where
i come to your door we sit and have a
call
call you tell me what you want i put it
in paper
we get some sample wheels and write it
all down if you want to do a follow-up
meeting with the family
then there you go with your presentation
you're trying to figure out the pricing
of that and
sure cynthia why wouldn't you try that
other than the fact that you're so busy
in real estate right now
you'd have to carve out some intentional
time but uh chrissy knows how to help
you do that why wouldn't you try that
because you have no pressure right now
i've done a few of them but uh i even
asked all of my family members okay i do
you guys for free just so i can get some
leverage under my belt you know some
expertise but nobody's a goal for it
nobody wants to talk about it no they
don't i said
wouldn't it be better for you to put
plants in place you know
okay so i mean i've done a few
obituaries for family members you know
just out of the courtesy but
i think it's just so important to have
the real kid in place you know
sure well we talk about that a lot of
times on the show i mean it's such a
gift to your family members that you're
leaving behind
here's an idea cynthia i'm just to throw
this out there so when we
sell our um graduate survival guide our
teen products
we're not really selling it to the
teenager right we're selling it to the
uncle
that wants that teenager to not go into
credit card debt to live you know
dave's principles and so on so you're
who you're selling to is not the
recipient
i wonder if you don't reach out to the
younger generation the adult children of
the people that actually need the will
you know that you're talking about
because there's a more of an incentive
for them
to have their parents do it like i have
any time that someone has
passed away whether it's someone uh that
i know in our community or even um
you know extended family i go to my mom
and i'm like where's your stuff
where's your stuff what do you want i
know this is hard to talk about but i'm
your only child i want to honor your
wishes this is not fun for me or you
but where's your stuff so i am highly
motivated
for my mother to have this put together
because i want to honor her
and so i wonder if you're not if you
stop marketing to the people that don't
want to talk about it
rightly so and you instead reach their
children their adult children that have
some skin in the game have a little bit
more incentive for their
to honor their parents is that something
you might want to try
i love that angle i love that angle you
know
cynthia i'd add one thing i think
chrissy's absolutely right but i also
think that you might want to adjust your
approach instead of wanting to sit down
and talk about someone's impending death
why don't you focus on the actual pain
points
around the will kit do you understand
what i'm saying and mama bears done the
hard work for you and they spent
hundreds of thousands of dollars on
marketing and i would lead with the pain
point and what i mean by that is
it's almost in the form of a question
and if you can do that via
email social media uh maybe a text and
just a quick mention to somebody
and leave them leave them hanging with
it make them lose some sleep
at night over hey if you were to die
tomorrow
would your estate be in good hands would
it be easy for your family whatever
those
pain points are and mama bear lays those
out for you but instead of hey can i
come sit down and talk about your death
and what we need to do i i'm just saying
i'm not saying you put it that way but
it's all about pain points and it's all
about just leave it with somebody
and and i would begin to kind of uh
pepper that in maybe even on social
media and your network there
and begin to just confront people with
maybe a one-sentence
question and let people wrestle with it
let them come to you
that would be a thought and just keep
trying that's what business is cynthia
you know this from real estate
yeah don't quit you don't sell the very
first house or the very first person
you just keep trying try different
language try different
branding try different approaches
different pain points
different people just keep trying you
got this
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Applause]
paying off debt is smart saving and
investing
is smart but there's one key to winning
with money
that is often forgotten that's
protecting your family
from emergencies there are 10 kinds of
insurance coverage you might need based
on your life stage and we've built a
tool to show you
what coverage you need to add drop or
adjust
and it only takes five minutes we'll
even rank your to-do list by importance
and email it to you so you can get your
plan
in place fast it's called the coverage
checkup and it could be the most
important five minutes you spend today
donald h wrote in and i like how he put
it for anyone who has not completed this
checkup
do it now you never know when something
will happen
and you never want to leave your family
in a bad situation we were just talking
about that
get out your phone and text checkup
233789
that's check up to seven eight nine
don't let an emergency sneak up on you
protect
your family now ken coleman and i are
taking your calls
triple eight eight two five five two two
five and we
are talking about money always here on
the ramsey show
but can i also love to help you figure
out what your purpose is
is that a promotion is it a job change a
new company a new position is
it a side business or small business or
growing your business
maybe it's something else and of course
because we're celebrating
my new book take back your time being on
pre-sale
we are always talking about how to
manage your time and the correlation
between managing your time and managing
your money is pretty
pretty consistent it's amazing how
you need time to make money and
how that affects your ability to one or
the other so give us a call triple eight
eight two five five two two five and
we're going to go
to brian in flint michigan hey brian how
are you
good how are you guys great how can ken
and i help today
well i'm kind of in a predicament here
um
i'm a diesel mechanic by trade um
sorry i'm a little nervous but uh that's
okay take your time
what i got going on is i'm kind of in a
toxic work environment
um i've got a job offer on the plate
and it's more per hour
but we're trying to get out of debt if
if i get my numbers right we'll be out
by march
staying with my current job i work 60
hours a week
if not more so there's no no real home
life
and a lamp this new job is no overtime
a straight 40 hours
only two dollars an hour more
and the insurance is more expensive
benefits package isn't a hundred percent
better
i'm like like i said my current job it's
a lot of overtime a lot of you know
brian let me ask you this brian so i'm
assuming you called us and you've run
these numbers
and what i mean by numbers is have you
run the numbers on okay you got a two
dollar an hour bump
but it's back to 40 hours how does that
compare with the 60 hours you're putting
in now
uh with your current rate and then the
cost of
the uh the benefits going up and
everything so if you run the side by
side between current job and new offer
have you done that yeah if if i keep
the overtime and all that it's about
almost 30 000 a year
less to take the new job yeah that's
where my
that's where my predicament is it's like
well
if i stay at this track i'm looking at
march we're looking at march to be out
of debt
well but but you also have to take into
consideration brian that you're freeing
up
20 hours in your week that you could go
take another part-time job do something
else that brings you joy
gets you out of this toxic environment
and you're still able to up your income
a little bit to maybe still stay on
track
okay that's a possibility i'm not you
know what i mean like that's one option
on the table
when you called us you gave us an either
or which way were you leaning before the
call started
you know uh i've been leaning both ways
like
do i stick it out just to make sure you
know make us
pick on our plan brian
brian i want to know i know you've been
going both ways
but you were leaning one direction i
just know it which way were you leaning
before you called us
partially sticking with my my job
currently yeah and the reason is is
because you know
what you've got there you're working 60
hours
you keep this up and you can you can gut
it out you can keep it going it's not
fun
but march is going to be here before you
know it so my question is let's go to
the future
okay because i i think this is almost a
false choice for you
it's less about dropping back to 40
hours a week
okay and it's more about what's the
future look like
so let's fast forward to march you're
out of debt
okay and you've been working so hard and
let's say that you backed off the
overtime
what would you be wanting to do long
term do you want to stay as a diesel
mechanic or would you want to
move into something else or do we stay
as a diesel mechanic where we are or
diesel mechanics somewhere else what's
that look
uh like always been my passion to be a
diesel mechanic
great um so are you thinking you're
gonna drop back
on the hours after we get out of debt in
march
i would hope i would hope to well wait a
second what do you mean
what do you mean you hope to or do you
not have a choice right now
i i do have the choice to drop it back
or
continue pounding it pounding out the
hours
well but you're saying there's no home
life who's on the other end of that and
what do they feel about you staying at
60 hours a week
after we get out of debt well i got a
wife and
a daughter and they wife would like to
see me home
a lot more well i got to tell you
speaking as the resident husband on the
panel i would do that
i would be gazelle intense i think she's
probably on board with the 60 hours for
the reasons
but but i would then you know start to
drop back and maybe
you know kind of wean yourself off of
the 60 hours because you want to get to
baby step 3 in that emergency fund as
well
but i would do that so i i got to tell
you
i wouldn't take the new job based on
what you're telling me christy you see
anything else there
you got anything else on that on no i
will say though i always
i don't like situations where i feel
painted in a corner with two bad options
bad option here is i'm taking a 30 000
pay cut bad option here as i'm staying
in a toxic work environment
i just encourage you um to look at other
options so brian you can stick this out
march will be here before you know it
this is not a if you were saying this is
three years from now
we'd be like okay let's assess a
different path to get there you staying
on this path
and be like hey we're gonna buckle down
for this season until march we got our
eye on the prize we're so close to the
finish line
you can do it and you will do it but
it's not
a bad thing if you want to explore what
it would look like
to fill those other 20 hours so you're
not home anymore but you may be happier
you may be earning income in those 20
hours that's an
option on the table but i think i think
ken's right you're the
low-hanging fruit the quickest win is to
stick with what you've got what you know
has good benefits has the income you
need and then in march you re-evaluate
what you want to do
evaluate your pay evaluate your schedule
evaluate everything because you're
debt-free and you've got
some more margin and flexibility there
that you've worked so hard for yeah and
i and i would lean into the toxic part i
think that's right i think i'm hearing
toxic thrown around a lot
i get it but but that is a very good
point
and i do think that if it truly is toxic
then diesel mechanics are always going
to be needed
whether it's diesel specific or just
your mechanical abilities are so
transferable
so in that situation brian now we're
looking for a different
different opportunity so you would be
doing what i call doing the right thing
in the wrong place if it truly is a
toxic environment i believe
that there's definitely some
difficulties there but you're just
looking for a different place
where whatever's going on in that
workplace is not happening
as much so i i'd sit tight and then
let's look to move on
after we get out of baby step two we
appreciate the trust and and appreciate
the call that really is a tough
situation where
your gazelle intense and you're going
good grief this is exhausting
it is and i think that's that's the
other thing too where it's like you can
buckle down for a season
and we all have to do that at times um
but maybe there's maybe there's another
path there if not then you buckle down
for that season and when
march comes you open up your options
for anyone listening right now if you
are feeling so busy and you don't know
why
you're feeling out of balance you're
feeling like i'm exhausted all the time
and i have no idea
how i got myself in this place text
busy to 33789 and take my life balance
quiz to get to the root
of why you feel that way and what to do
about it
that's busy to 33789
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
kristy wright sitting in with me today
is ken coleman and we're taking your
calls about life
and money triple eight eight two five
five
two two five and we are going to go to
augusta with kendall hey kendall how are
you
doing wonderful how are you guys doing
good how can ken and i help
awesome i would just call into you ask a
question
um i'm a travel nurse and i've been
working like a madman trying to pay down
my debt
currently paid off about 30 grand in
about four months
awesome um and i just paid off my car
i did a stupid thing as your dad would
say with my card and i had it
alone he's not my dad kendall it's a
real thing everybody thinks he is i just
feel like i need to clarify really for
america that dave ramsey is not my dad
can we just have a moment yeah he's not
i'm i'm flattered i'm sorry everybody
ken everyone thinks he's my dad i get
this on social media all the time
kendall continue just want to clarify he
has a daughter rachel cruz who's a
personality
his daughter denise whittemore who works
for the ramsey family foundation
i'm a ramsay personality not his
daughter now we can go on kendall let me
let's have it you got
you paid off your car i just felt like
we needed to clarify that for america
sorry so i paid off the car um
and the car still showed his value
fairly well of course it's going to
depreciate
so the car now is probably worth between
13 and 14 grand
um and i'm turning away and probably by
the end of december just of my own it's
just working the way i
am i'll be able to knock out the rest of
the credit card debt that i have
uh as well as a personal loan there's
probably about 10 grand left on that
i'll be able to take care of both of
those by december
well me just trying to be you know
overzealous
should i sell my car that's paid for and
use that 13 grand
to further knock down my debt and just
buy a little cash card
um just to get around with again i'm the
travel nurse anyway so
a vehicle that i get is going to have a
ton of mouse put on it
um it just needs something to get me to
where i'm going for as my next
assignment is concerned
or should i just stay on track keep
working like i am
pay off the debt i'm just using my job
and my income which i'm making pretty
good money at this point
and just keep my car and don't worry
about it that one
that one kendall because listen you need
your car it's incredibly important to
the work that you
do and you're so close i totally hear in
your voice you're just excited and you
want to fast track this and we get
people calling in
all the time that have that gazelle
intensity which is awesome but then
they're finding ways to try to get
around the plan like oh i'm going to
take out my retirement to try to pay off
the debt faster no no let's just stick
to the plan
you got this this is a marathon not a
sprint i want you to pace yourself
you're doing great on the plan that
you're on you're being super aggressive
already you're gonna have it paid off
really soon
and oh by the way you need that car and
so even if you
sold the car and then had to buy a new
car there's there's a cost
in the headache and even financial of
the of going through that process
and i just honestly i just don't even
want you to have to deal with it so keep
the car
keep the car stay on the plan and you
will be debt-free before you know it but
i love your
enthusiasm i think that's awesome i
think you're just excited but just stick
with the plan you got this
all right we're going to go to ellen in
chicago hey ellen how are you
doing good how can i help what you got
going on
well i have
a chronic medical condition okay and
last year i spent a huge amount of time
in the hospital oh i'm sorry
uh this year i spent i've had two
hospitalizations luckily
i've not been in the hospital for three
months so okay um
very grateful for that however i'm
looking to the future eventually
this is going to force me to
retire early slash go on disability i'm
sure
okay and i don't want to do that i don't
want to go on disability
so i'm looking i i closed
a side hustle i had that was just
leaking money right and left and
i had no idea on the finances and stuff
and i closed it
um the temptation is going back to doing
the same thing which was
selling on ebay and etsy i will not sell
on amazon again
ever again as a third-party seller
um but other things i could think about
is you know
you know obviously the financial
coaching through you guys
or but what i really want to do and it's
a very very tiny niche market
is i am a hand spinner which means i
make my own yarn
i'm also a somewhat of an expert
in different breeds of sheep and
there's a possibility there is uh
basically
you know festivals throughout the united
states and guilds that would hire people
to give presentations and
i'm that's really the thing that i would
love to do
that was kind of the first thing i
wanted to do
um back in the back and i
you know there's there's a push for me
to go you got to have something that's
going to bring in a reasonable amount of
money
and um and then there's a fear factor
of uh you know imposter syndrome
yeah going on with this how much money
how much money you need to bring in
if you're not going to be on disability
if i'm not going to be on disability
i would need to probably bring in at
least uh
30 to 40 000 a year and i'm guessing
this hand spinning
uh craft show thing will not bring that
in
no right no okay so i'm not opposed to
you
um pursuing that on the side kind of for
fun almost like a hobby and bonus money
where it's like
when those shows come up and if you can
get booked to do that
but that's the bonus money that's not
the primary plan because it can't
support you financially
and the last thing you need when you
already have everything that you're
dealing with with your health ellen
the last thing you need is the financial
burden of having
a business that does not bring in the
money that you need to live on
because just like ken and i were talking
about earlier business
can support you you can choose a
business outlet you can choose an
industry you can choose a path
that can bring in not just good money
you can choose one that brings in great
money
and so i want you to figure out what
that is and
do that as your main thing it doesn't
have to be going back to ebay
it could be something completely
different you already know how to start
something so that's a that's a great
step in the process but it needs to be
something that can support
i got a question question for you uh
real quick i i'm going somewhere
i don't know if it's going to lead
anywhere what what talent or skills do
you have
that makes you a good yarn spinner
forgive my ignorance this is true
ignorance but
are you is it sewing is it help me out
what is that
okay i am a teacher okay my current
position can
is i am eit help desk uh service desk
agent okay i am best on the phone
walking people through either doing
troubleshooting which i'm very good at
or
teaching them how to use outlook or
excel
or what they need to do for requesting
certain type of information okay let me
ask you now
so you don't have to share what the
chronic but what it is if you're
comfortable tell us but i'm asking to
say
how will that affect your ability to be
on the
phone with people or via zoom and walk
them
guide them instruct them through some
type of technology process how will it
affect that
um if
if i'm ex okay if i'm on the phones i'm
i'm good
okay my my my i have heart fit i have
chronic um
digestive heart failure okay gotcha and
which i also have a few uh you know some
other core
you know other stuff that goes along
with it gotcha all right let me ask you
this because our time is limited we got
about a minute so i'm gonna i'm gonna
move really quick okay
okay so your specialty is is guiding the
teaching in the technology field yes
specialty is writing and teaching in
anything i used to teach at a community
college
okay so here's what i want you to do
ellen here's the homework assignment
uh i agree with what christy said as the
hobby but because
your heart failure and any of that
that's not going to preclude you from
teaching and guiding people on the phone
and with the internet and i'm telling
you with the movement that we've seen
post pandemic
to online teaching because you're a
community college professor i would look
into
online teaching my wife has got a dear
friend from our time in atlanta
and she went from high school teacher to
full-time
online teaching adults and continuing
education it is a
exploding industry i want you to look
into where you can teach and what you
can teach online and do that from home
anywhere you got a computer i think
that's a good direction for you ellen
stay on the phone i'ma have kelly give
you a
ticket to the business boutique
conference in october you can attend via
live stream you don't have to come in
person
october 14th through the 16th those
speakers and that content will give you
what you need to figure out your idea
and get it off the ground you can do
this
i want to thank producer ben associate
producer kelly and
my co-host ken this is the ramsey show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this
is the ramsay show where america hangs
out to have a conversation about your
life
and your money i'm christy wright i am a
business coach and author and i'm joined
today
by my good friend career expert and
also author ken coleman and we
are taking your calls it's friday we're
in a great mood and we
are here for you to answer your calls
whether it's about money
life career business
maybe just managing your time because
we've been talking about that a lot
lately with my new book take back your
time being out
whatever you need we are here for you
we're going to go to joe in arlington
virginia hey joe how are you
hey uh this is joe uh i'm calling in
i've recently graduated
college i haven't i just i found a job
so i started working that about a month
ago
i also bought a car earlier in like this
in the end of december
for thirty one thousand dollars and
right now i can with the
car prices going back up it was brand
new i can return it i can sell to car
max for about the same price and i was
just wondering
what your guys's thoughts were about
that yeah what do you what do you make
joe
so i make about 85 000 okay and
uh their loan is a zero percent loan
sales either thinking about
just selling the car now and just taking
back the decision that i made with about
like a 800
loss it's not a big deal to me at this
moment but
i just wouldn't have a car yeah and or
my other option would be to just keep
paying their
loan to keep paying the loan as well as
possible because i know that's against
what you guys say but it's like a zero
percent loan so i figured that
with the 5 with the 500 a month payments
like i could
potentially get a higher return that
return from that money risk-free
so yeah that's never risk-free i can
guarantee that joe
i think your first uh inclination to
sell the car is absolutely dead-on yes
sell the car um do you have any savings
i have about 13 000 in my roth ira
and then i have about 10 000 in a
brokerage and about
probably like 2 000 in cash okay
well i mean here's the thing if you can
use public transportation for a little
bit to save up some cash
maybe save up another couple thousand
dollars you can use
a thousand dollars from your savings a
couple thousand that you save up in the
next few months hopefully
and then you can buy yourself a used car
that'll get you around
in the meantime and then save up and pay
cash as you upgrade your car this is not
something
that you want to take out a loan for
cars depreciate
in value every single time even though
the market's weird right now and used
cars are
you know are hot right now because
manufacturing with cove and all that
they still depreciate they will continue
to depreciate and you can't afford
a thirty one thousand dollar car joe
even on a really good income you can't
afford that and no zero percent is not
zero risk every single time it's a bad
idea and so what we want you to do is
just take out
uh about a thousand dollars from your
savings um keep a thousand in there a
thousand dollars from your savings save
up another couple thousand and buy you
something
good used use public transportation in
the meantime
um yeah because in arlington i i i know
that area well i mean the metro is going
to take him anywhere he probably can go
and need to go
in arlington virginia i mean it's just
like being in new york without a car
it's really a non-factor yeah so that's
a no-brainer yeah
sell the car sell the car sell the car
all right we're going to
ashley in oklahoma city hey ashley how
are you
hi i'm good how are you good what's
going on
well earlier this year my husband and i
found out
that my mother-in-law had taken credit
cards and loans out in his name
that he had no idea and what
we know got we got our first mortgage
and we had a crazy interest rate
and they had called me and a credit card
had been turned over to collections
we've talked to her about it and you
know asked her to buckle down and pay it
and she's not
i mean she's giving us the minimum
payment but that's all we're getting
and anytime we try to talk to her about
it it's so forfeiting for me
and i don't know what to do okay okay
let's back up here so first of all first
of all
playing the victim is a strategy
it's called manipulation so i don't care
if she's your mom my mom anybody's mom
doesn't matter
that she's a sweet little mother-in-law
or mother that's manipulative
incredibly it's also theft that was
theft
identity theft so again even if you're
related it doesn't change the fact that
it's illegal
and not okay at all in any way
so um ashley i don't know
if you do this or your husband does this
i would say he would need to do it but
you can tell me whether or not this is
realistic
but there needs to be a conversation a
very different conversation that looks
like this
you pay it off or i'm turning you in
for identity theft yeah has that
happened
that is the conversation i've tried to
push him to that
but he seems to be taking it a little
easy on her
yeah how much money are we talking about
um the personal loan was ten thousand
and then
about another four or five in credit
cards
and her excuse was i did it to help you
guys
okay well i gotta know more what do you
mean she did it to help
what was it for what was the money spent
on that's supposed to help you
nothing literally nothing okay we are
very self-sufficient we take care of
ourselves
okay your husband your husband
needs to grow a pair it's time where's
the hustle where's the dad in this
situation
just say it ken just said he's on the
road so he really he didn't realize this
was going on
but okay so so this is a family listen
i hate that you're even calling um i
hope you maybe
maybe show your husband this call i'd
like to speak to him for a moment what's
his name his name's bo
bo where are you bo okay so i'm going to
talk to bo for a second and you can get
today's youtube show and you can
get it right to this point bo here's the
deal man your wife's got more guts than
you do
and your mom is is in is in a very
unhealthy place
and you're allowing it to happen and it
is affecting your life and your marriage
and this needs to be dealt with i think
christie's right i go with her and say
mom
dad fix it now pay it off now
or i'm turning you in but you're but you
don't have the guts to do that bo
and so here's what's gonna happen
because you're afraid to be a man
and talk to mommy and tell her that what
she did was wrong
you're going to end up having such sick
toxicity and resentment toward her
because this is never
going to go away and your dad has
has the same problem you have neither
one of you you or your dad
have got what it takes you just don't
because you'd have done something by now
and you need to grow a pair both of you
maybe you share the pair
and you talk and sit down and get this
handle because this is
bad they need to fix it and i think the
time for talking is over
ashley i'm sorry i i i'm sorry you had
to call in
the conversation needs to go like this
pay it off by this date
or we're turning you in and then when
that date comes
turn her in and follow through this is
illegal
and insanely manipulative and the more
you allow it to happen
the more it is on you don't let it
happen
fix it now this is
the ramsay show
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over 70 dollars
a month
by switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com
and enter the promo code ramsey to save
50 off your first month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
i'm christy wright and joining me today
is ken coleman
and according to last segment i'm not
the only one who's feisty on friday
just gonna throw that out there we are
taking your calls giving advice
and we got opinions no shortage of those
here
we are here for you give us a call
triple eight eight two five five
two two five we are here to help you
with your money decisions but let's be
honest most of the time it's not really
just about money
there's a relationship issue at play
there's some other dynamic and we end up
getting
to the root issue to help you
in all areas of your life
also if you are in debt speaking of
money
and you know what it feels like to just
feel like you're drowning in bills you
may feel like
you're never going to get ahead i know
what that feels like
i remember i remember making those
payments when i was working my way out
of debt
here's the good news it doesn't have to
be that way
when you attack this debt like your life
depends on it it will
take back your paycheck and start
building the life
that you want and we're going to help
you do just that
with our class financial peace
university in this class you will learn
our proven
plan step-by-step plan that has helped
millions
pay off their debt fast but you'll never
make the changes you need to pay off
your debt unless you stick to a budget
that's why you also get the premium
version of our budgeting tool
called every dollar and it's all only
available with a ramsey plus membership
you can get ahead you can become debt
free
you can manage your money and feel in
control
start your free trial of ramsay plus and
end this constant battle for your money
just text trial to 33789
that's trial two three three seven
eight nine and ken and i are answering
your calls triple eight
eight two five five two two five we're
going to go to daniel in
phoenix hey daniel how are you
hey christy hey how come can i help
you're taking my call
sure um yeah i'm just calling because um
my family and i we just moved to phoenix
and from maui
about like three or four months ago and
um i just don't know what to do next
we're in baby step two and
when we're in maui you know we we paid
off quite a bit of debt
i think close to like 37 000
and we saw a student loan left and um
yeah just moving to phoenix i took a
really big uh pay cut i'm in
construction
um i installed known in tile and
i took a pretty pretty good pay cut you
know like probably like the 40 percent
paid cut
and it's just been really hard i mean we
cashflowed the move and we haven't been
creating any more debt but um
even when we were living you know on
maui i
i just i didn't i didn't really even
want to do you know
the trade that i'm in you know like long
term but i just
stuck it out uh you know we wanted to
get gazelle intense and pay off debt and
we did and
now it's like now we're new in town we
have family here which is really cool
but
i just i'm just not feeling motivated
um just because of the pay cut and
just because you know i know i don't
want to do this forever so
sure well let me before we dive into
what you want to do you still have
plenty of motive
you should because you still got some
debt to pay off and you've done such a
great job i mean the amount of money
that you put towards the debt snowball
is no
uh that's not an easy thing to do and
you did it and so your motivation right
now
is i'm still in the middle of this thing
i got to get out of it but let's let's
look
further um a guy who's been
doing tile and in a trade like that so
you've got a lot of time we're kind of
working on your own you got a lot of
time to think am i right
yeah yeah so what have you thought about
what what
what would you even say ken i'm not even
sure i know how to get there
uh i've got some fear i've got some
doubt but if i remove all that
and i knew i could succeed and what
would you try
not even commit the rest of your
professional life to it but what would
you try
you know i've been thinking about i like
being a technician
you know just now i'm a technician with
like being an installer and
i just thought about the same thing
maybe like in the medical field
yeah but it just seems like
you know i i feel like i'm getting in
the way of myself
yeah i'm afraid to just because you know
i'd have to go to school again for that
and hold on hold on hold on hold on
don't assume that now
unless you're not telling me when you
say technician be more specific and then
have you researched
and found out that the only way to get
in that field and do that
is a degree or the best way to get in
that field and do that is with a degree
answer those questions um
you know i've spent maybe like an hour
total just
you know looking up you know different
jobs like in the medical field and
you know that doesn't require a whole
lot of schooling um i've looked at maybe
like uh
i think it's called like like
radiography like mri techs
or like x-ray technicians okay and
what's the answer
is is is a degree the only way or the
best way to get in those
um i think eventually it is
i'm not too sure i think there's like
you can get certified
yes okay so here's the deal let me just
back this out of the details because i
don't want to put you completely on the
spot and you've given me enough here
so here's the deal you have you've got
this technical talent this mechanical
making is what i would call it this
making talent this imagination where you
can lay tile and make it look great
and then the technician you use the word
technician and that's really the way
your brain works
so there there are a lot of things that
you can do that you're good at
and that you love that's talent and
passion and so i think
more than an hour is required uh but i
don't think it's a whole lot more time
but i think you've got to
really allow yourself to wonder again
like a child does when they come into
this world they ask
hundreds of questions a day poor
christie's right in the middle of it
okay
with three kids under six they just
naturally ask questions you've got to
get that curiosity back up to say okay
the talent that i have the type of work
i like to do the technical nature the
detailed nature
precision type work you've outlined that
what are all the different things i can
do and you started the process let's do
it a little bit more
and then there's another step that i
call clarify and verify so here's what
you got to do
you've already identified some of those
technical positions in medicine or in
the
the healthcare field i want you to i
know you're new to town but you got
family
you can find somebody who's doing that
work and do coffee
a zoom call a phone call and go back to
high school or college like you're doing
a term paper on that person's job
and ask them everything about it how
they got there how they got qualified
what they like the most what they like
the least you get the drill
and in clarifying what goes into getting
there and what goes into doing the role
your heart will then verify either ding
ding ding or
and that's the process but you got to
find more options and then once we
figure that out we go okay
i know what i'd like to do now i have a
good idea
what it takes to get qualified when we
begin that process so
get your head up uh you've got a lot to
offer
you just gotta get yourself out there
and pay attention and see what you could
do
and then choose and then get qualified
get connected while you're there in
phoenix you're gonna begin to meet
people and then the opportunity will
present itself but this is not a scary
path do you understand what i'm saying
absolutely daniel i've got one quick
question before we before we let you go
um you you just sound discouraged
you just sound down because i know you
can make these google searches i know
you can do this work ken's telling you
to do but i'll be honest i don't know if
you're going to do it
what's going on why are you so down why
are you so discouraged
um i think i mean my wife she started to
work part time
from home we have a we have a son um
he's gonna be 16 months in and um
it's just really stressful at the house
like in terms of money i just feel like
we're really close to the edge
with money and um it's just
i just i feel like the surge because we
were
we went from like thriving like in
hawaii we were just
you know paying off so much so much debt
and we saved up a lot of money to move
out here and cash flow that and then now
it's
like we've slowly have bled through like
our savings
yeah i'm living here and um just like
we just got so good out of being
developed pets like on the island
that like our living expenses are
actually a little bit more here
yeah well here's the thing daniel you're
doing the right thing but it feels like
a step back because it is
financially it doesn't have to be
doesn't have to mean that you can't make
these steps forward you will when you do
what tim
can ask you to also stay on the line
let's give you a free
membership to ramsey plus for a year you
will get constant encouragement and
motivation that will fire you back up
when you start to feel discouraged show
you how to get a bigger shovel
since you've had a step back you're
going to get back in the game
you just need a little gusto might need
a little motivation reduce the stress at
home do what ken asked you to do
[Music]
you got this this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm kristy wright and joining me today
is ken coleman and we are taking your
calls about your life and your money
give us call triple eight eight two five
five two two five and we will answer
your questions and
i'm so excited because thomas and cassie
are
here on our debt-free stage how are you
guys very good how are you doing good
good you are on the debt-free stage
which can only mean one thing you
are debt-free tell me how much debt did
you pay off
we paid off 198 256 dollars
whoo that's a lot of money what kind of
debt was this uh it was broken down
into two-car loans one debt
consolidation loan and eight credit
cards
oh okay how long did that take 24 months
oh my goodness
all right whoo okay so that's a lot of
money in 24 months y'all were busting it
we were
what was your range of income during
this time we started at 130 and we
finished at 166 000.
all right what happened how did you get
that income up i
took a promotion at work and put that to
the dead
come on yeah there you go that's how you
get that shovel bigger good awesome
good night y'all we're moving fast okay
so
so 24 months ago what happened because
that's a 198 000.
that's a lot of debt what happened 24
months ago so 24 months ago my wife and
i were scammed
by a family friend he opened up a
business um
had us co-signed for a car loan and
co-signed for a
credit card and um we didn't catch it
until it was too late he'd already run
up
25 000 in debt and so we self-repo'd the
car and
got rid of that and then said we need to
get out of that
okay so that's what started at the scam
is what what's but you had other debt
other than that correct yeah we had we
had previous debt going into it but we
figured
we might as well just attack it and get
rid of it yeah
yeah so that'll that'll that'll shake
you yeah nothing
and and like the previous caller that
was on the show we did actually turn it
into law enforcement so yeah
because i am a law enforcement officer
so okay okay
all right well yeah so sometimes that's
that's
if they don't respond that's that's what
you've got to do exactly okay so you're
a law enforcement officer i am
okay what else did is that the only uh
job you had during this time when you're
paying off debt yep
all right way to go that's awesome so
now you've got it paid off how does it
feel amazing it feels great
you actually get to keep your money when
you're paid i bet you feel like you got
a huge race oh
every day yeah actually i actually enjoy
going to work yeah
there you go it'll change how you do the
work
who were your biggest cheerleaders
through this whole process
our kids our kids my parents um and then
extended family members that are
ramsey so you know they run financial
peace through their church up in
washington
so awesome and you guys are from where
uh we're from rancho cordova california
okay so we're on an epic road trip yeah
you are
that's awesome that is amazing what
happens when
uh you realize hey i've been basically
defrauded
yeah and i'm in big trouble were you
familiar with financial peace university
were you not familiar with the ramsay
show ramsey i mean
how did you get into this oh i was
definitely familiar with ramsey i
listened to him
to and from work before i got into law
enforcement my wife had read the book
and said we need to get on board and we
need to do this and
my parents are definitely ramsey's
solution
uh i guess promoters yeah sure um and
they encouraged us to come down to
the live event in san diego for uh when
he was talking about finances
um before this whole thing happened and
so you know that was kind of what
kick-started us to really move it into
gear
and you know get rid of it so you had
the debt
you already had some of your own debt
right and then you
you knew about us you knew about the
total money makeover been to a live
event but it was just this
idea correct but getting scammed that's
what sets you into action
okay all right this is going to light a
fire under us to actually
turn this thing around 100 yeah wow
wow what a story i mean hey i hate that
happened to you
but look where you are now because of it
so yeah wait good for you for turning
this thing
turning this thing around all right what
would you say for everybody listening
right now
and they are in your shoes of paying off
that debt they're you know
going to work working the extra jobs
working the extra hours what's the
secret what's the key
to getting out of debt like
communication
communication and then just weekly
status check-ins with your spouse you
know through this whole process it's
definitely brought my wife and i closer
together
in regards to just talking about
finances but also realizing that
you know as dave says a budget tells
your money where to go instead of
wondering where it went and you know we
realized hey we actually can
pull more money out of the budget and
put it here and put it there and
the other thing is just figuring out
want versus need yeah i'm a spender by
habit
yeah and so i had to curtail a lot of
that and realize that yeah i don't need
it
you know it's a desire and let's get rid
of the debt and then we can deal with it
there you go i'm curious that's really
interesting that you say that about
uh status check-ins thomas that's really
interesting i teach people to connect
with their spouse weekly
on their time and their calendar but
you're talking about with money and it's
so important with both what did that
look like for you guys what was the
status check in what did that look like
on a
on a weekly or monthly basis you know
manly was just sitting around the
dining room table and just saying okay
where are we at you know
do we have any extra money we can put
towards this debt you know
and just really getting that time where
we can just talk about it and
not being afraid to have that
conversation yeah i know a lot of times
spouses don't like to talk about
finances because it leads to a whole
negative thing but
we actually leaned in on each other and
said okay let's tackle this together as
a family
yeah it's amazing when you have a shared
goal how it can
bring you closer as a team because
you're high fiving it oh we've got this
extra amount or we can cut spending here
and
um it gives you language to it but also
gives you this this shared motivation to
that finish line
and you guys are there well you all are
amazing well done
well done for you now and in all
fairness we rated the kids banks
accounts
oh really yes so i got to ask you this
is a lot of money
it is in 24 months there had to be some
major moments
curious if you could share one of those
and then was there also a moment in the
journey
where it's a slog and then you felt like
okay now we've got some real momentum
and emotionally you begin to see okay
now we're hitting hitting this ground
running was there a moment like that
well when we repo
the car and turned that back in we were
still upside down 7 000 on it
and so you know we said okay um
you know and it's just a matter of of
you know talking about it not being
afraid to talk about it it's tough
i mean i'm not gonna yeah 198 000 in two
years
is a lot of money yeah and and uh you
know yeah you you did
you know christmas was a little
difficult but we started financing for
that and
budgeting for that and saying okay we're
going to take a little bit out of each
paycheck and
stuff like that we can't have no
christmas you planned for it yeah you
plan for it
just changes your behavior well it goes
right into the budget okay we're gonna
we're gonna take this line item off okay
christmas is done let's put that extra
money towards the debt and
keep plugging away at it well y'all are
amazing well done
that's an incredible feat and here you
stand on the other side of it well done
well we have a copy of the legacy
journey
because that is definitely the next
chapter in your journey and
we have a copy of the total money
makeover that you can give to someone
else as a gift
pay it forward hopefully set them on
this path
as well all right y'all we've got thomas
and cassie with tyler
and caitlin paid off 198
thousand dollars in 24 months making a
range of 130
to 166 000
count it down for me let's hear a debt
free scream
three two one
[Applause]
oh that's awesome ken that's a lot of
money no
almost two hundred thousand 000 in two
years
making 166 at the top those are some
major
sacrifices but now here they are
completely debt free
yeah not a single payment to worry about
and that is just i think with
with people listing right now if you're
listening right now and you have this
mountain of debt
a hundred thousand two hundred thousand
it feels impossible
when you're looking at the mountain uh
you know i love a good running example
when i'm running a hill i don't look at
the top of the hill i'm like just get to
that mailbox
just get to that mailbox get to that
fire hydrant get to that light post get
to that tree
and if you can break it down just like
we teach in the debt snowball break it
down
into the baby steps into your debt
snowball and you just tackle it one
step at a time you'll get there you'll
get to the top of that mountain
you'll get that debt paid off you'll be
calling in to us doing your debt-free
scream and you will never
look back i tell people all the time the
voice of debt is always the voice of
regret
no one loves their debt like oh i love
all these payments when you get there
you'll never look back
you'll never go back you'll never feel
like that again
so so so cool that's awesome thomas and
cassie
198 000 in two
years pretty impressive this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
i'm christy wright joining me today is
ken coleman and we are taking
your calls triple eight eight two five
five two two five had an awesome debt
free scream
the last segment and now we are going to
the phones we've got
dion in san diego california hey dion
how are you
i'm great how are you good how can can i
help
i want to know as a mother should i be
instructing my kids
to who are 18 20 and 22 to get a credit
card
to build up their credit for themselves
so that they can buy a home someday
do you need to build up credit to buy a
home someday
what are their best practices well
here's the thing dion it depends on who
you ask because if you ask about anyone
else anywhere
they will say yes you need a credit
score and you need a credit card and
you need this you can't do anything and
that's simply untrue
is it the easier way that's culturally
normal that everyone accepts yeah but
we're not
we're not normal here we're weird
because we want people to live their
lives debt-free we were just talking to
the couple that just did their debt-free
scream and they were in
las vegas and they printed we're
debt-free on m
m's and the person printing them at the
m m store said is this true like she
couldn't believe it
it's a weird way to live it's also the
better way to live
where you don't have debt the good news
is dionne is that you can oh ken's going
to show the m m's here
yeah i mean you're watching on youtube i
don't even know if they can zoom in or
the guys down below will but it's just
weird
free on the eminem by the way i'm gonna
eat it while you continue you know we're
just gonna
it's friday fantastic dion so so here's
the thing
they taste better debt-free m m's taste
better
wait dion's like will you please answer
my question and stop munching i have
adhd ah
i'm here for you listen all you have to
do is something called manual
underwriting for a mortgage
your kids your adult children will be
able to buy a house someday
and you can show proof of payment for
like electricity bills from rental
properties and other ways to show
for if you need some type of proof of
something to to rent an apartment or
whatever
it might be a slightly more work and
steps but it's worth it
to live your life debt-free the problem
dionne is that so many
high school students college students
and young adults they
in the name of building credit rack up
tons and tons of debt and they end up
calling us in their late 20s
asking how they can dig themselves out
of this mess that they made and they
didn't mean to
and it all started with a free t-shirt
or a free pizza or i need to build my
credit score
and they all end up a statistic in this
un
the most indebted generation in the
entire history of the world
and you just don't want that for your
kids right no you don't want that for
your kids
not not in the name of building credit
you can
do what you need to do live your life
even buy a house
without a credit score and without debt
in fact uh you know this is what
millions of people have done
if you'll stay on the line dion we will
send you a copy
of rachel cruz and dave ramsey's book
smart money smart kids they talk about
how to raise smart money smart kids
obviously they have some examples for
younger kids but even when you have
adult children
some of those principles of living
debt-free of not building a credit score
they are in there and that will give you
maybe some more language to talk to your
kids about it and give you the practical
steps on how to follow through
through on it i got to say this real
quick dia listen you better remember
what chrissy said because christie's
right
100 right but i'm going to tell you
you're going to go back and tell some
people
yeah i called the ramsay show and
christopher wright bestselling author
told me this and they're going to go
she's crazy she's just so excited about
she they need a credit score they're
wrong
please read the book please do your own
homework
she's right they don't have to have a
credit score
to live a very desirable life please
please please because i'm everybody's
going to tell
oh she doesn't know what she's talking
about yeah actually
she does know what she's talking about i
just want to warn you when you tell
people what you're going to do they're
going to say that well and it's like
dave always says don't take
finance advice from broken people the
people saying oh they need a credit
score are broke
they're part of that statistic too with
credit cards and bills and credit card
debt up to their eyeballs so
of course they think that's normal
because they're a part of that i'm
telling you
ken and i don't have credit cards we
teach people every day
how to live your life without credit
cards credit scores debt
i don't even know what my credit score
is i i would assume mine's a zero
because i don't do anything
i don't know anyway anyway i hope that
helps all right let's go to kyle in new
orleans hey kyle how are you
hey i'm doing good thanks for taking my
calls sure how can i help
so my call is more about a life advice
kind of question than a financial
question although it has financial
confidence
so i'm going to lay a few of those out
for you just to set the stage
um i'm a programmer i i just turned 33
oh
i'm a light bloomer too i'll just say
that right off the bat i'm a late
bloomer
i have been working at the same job for
uh seven years and that's seven years
ago is when i graduated from college
i have a bs in mathematics and
the issue is i knew from day one
of getting this job um that it wasn't
really going to be
it wasn't really going to do it for me
in the long run that it wasn't going to
provide the sense of fulfillment that i
think i need
from a career maybe i'm wrong you're
right
you're right by the way don't ignore
that
and i am i have just been
struggling that's created this sort of
malaise over me
that's been with me for like five to
seven years
and i've tried my best to like
break through that malaise in those
seven years and
get to a place where i can like
decompress and reassess
for the next career move and i've tried
to
like i've tried my best to avoid the the
unpardonable sin of
like quitting a job without having
anything lined up
but i i mean i'm getting 33 i mean i'm
not getting any younger this
it feels like this is something that if
i don't do now i'm just never going to
do it
all right all right so hold on so kyle i
i appreciate
you laying this out but when someone
says i've tried to break out of the
malaise
you're you're trying the wrong thing you
need to find something
go go dig and develop a plan
and move into it when the opportunity
opens up not try to
break through the malaise here's the
reality there's tons of research out
there
but the most recent research came last
year in 2020
out of london where it showed that if
you are in a job
that you have no meaning for
that the emotional and mental duress
is close to the grief
that comes when losing a loved one
so this malaysia you're talking about is
very very real but to try to break
through
that and just gut through it you're not
going to be able to what you've got to
do
is move on and right out of college you
knew this was not a long term play
so what's the long term play a guy who's
been thinking about this for five to
seven years
has had an idea or two come from his
heart we've only got about a
minute and a half tell me what it is
what's the thing you would love to try
well i wish that i could do something
that involves like mentoring and like
teaching people more
teaching people what be really specific
right now and don't overthink this what
would you like to teach people what
subject matter
something to do with math or science um
something that i believe is objective
truth that will
empower them awesome hey can i tell you
something
kyle that's a fantastic answer so let's
let's just play this out real quick i
got seven stages
that'll lead to the work you were born
to do get clear at stage
one i think you're pretty close to
walking into stage two which is get
qualified so you've gotta ask yourself
if i was gonna teach where would i teach
this is homework you need to do secondly
what would it take to get me there what
education would i need what do i need to
learn
what experience would i need what do i
need to do how much is that going to
cost me that's the economic question and
then finally
how long is it going to take me to do
those things that's the expectation
question
those four questions will yield answers
that become a plan this is what i need
to learn
this is what i need to do here's how
much it's going to cost me and
based on my financial reality here's how
long that is going to take
now my man i just want you to feel for a
second just for one second
what if you on monday morning showed up
and were teaching
science and math at the end of the day
you were driving home what do you think
that might feel like
oh boy um good or bad kyle
i would think it would feel good
yes there you go so don't overthink this
when you think about work you want to do
how does it make you feel go after that
i want to thank producer ben associate
producer kelly
and my co-host ken coleman
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section
or head to thermzyshow.com thanks for
[Music]
listening
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your
life and your money i'm christy wright
and joining me today
is my good friend ken coleman and we are
here
for you we're taking your calls at
triple eight eight two five
five two two five if you have a question
about money
paying off your debt faster what to save
for
how to work the baby steps we're here
for you
give us a call triple 825-5225 and
if you follow ken or myself then you
probably know we love to talk about
more than just money i love helping
people with businesses so if you have a
business question call in for that
a question about your career maybe what
your next step is
and of course because my new book take
back your time
the guilt-free guide to life balance is
now available for pre-sale
we are taking all questions about time
management
productivity balance how
we can do what matters most to create a
sense of balance in your life give us a
call
triple eight eight two five five two two
five i got a question about the news yes
let's have it uh that is available so
when you were diving through this a lot
of this comes from your own personal
experience i've heard you say you wrote
it for yourself which is the best kind
of book because you know it works
what are you finding that is maybe one
or two
of the biggest time suckers i know i'm
making that up that doesn't sound very
official but
you get my point where do you see a lot
of the stress there yeah well i go into
some of the time steelers in the
time steelers i like them yeah yeah
that's better i actually do really talk
about that in the book
but to me that is more of an ancillary
issue
yeah i think i think the core thing that
i really love to dig into through the
through the majority of the book and you
heard me talk about this at summit we
were at entre leadership summit together
but here's what i found about life
balance we don't know what it is
we just know we don't have it like like
if you ask people what this means to
them they can't really define it so it
becomes this shadow that haunts us
and we always feel like we're failing
and so while what i wanted to do in this
book ken is i wanted to redefine it
because i think many people don't have a
definition for it but they're always
asking about it's the number one
question i'm asked all the time but the
second thing is i think we feel an
incredible pressure
to do everything for an equal amount of
time or we do everything perfectly so
let's say you have a day where
you know let's say you put in a really
long day it's a 12-hour day 14-hour day
and at the end of the day you did what
was right because you knew that was
going to be a 14-hour day
that was gonna be a hard day you planned
your day around it but at the end of the
day
the inclination is well i didn't work
out i didn't spend time with my kids i'm
failing
and so the the implied pressure is we've
got to do everything every day
and we've got to do everything perfectly
and and i want to set people free from
that pressure
because they don't think it's true i
don't think it's realistic and i don't
think it's even desirable
and so the definition that i built this
whole book around is life balance
isn't doing everything for an equal
amount of time
it's about doing the right things at the
right time and when you do the right
things the right time you will feel that
sense of balance that you've been
looking for so for me
simply defining it for people and then
making it tactical through these five
steps to create balance that's what
takes this elusive idea that haunts us
and gives us practical application for
our life and sets us free from the guilt
and the pressure
to do everything every day and then you
can next time you can work that 14-hour
day and go hey
i did the right thing at the right time
i'm proud of how i used my time
and i actually feel balanced but it
wasn't because i did everything
because we're never going to do
everything perfectly and i hope it's a
message that really sets people free
i think it will because i think that one
simple statement that you made is very
profound
it's it's not about doing everything
it's the right thing yeah
that does really make a person feel like
uh what has been
kind of called balanced it's just it
makes you feel
focused on hey this is where my focus is
i've heard you say that
when i'm at work i'm focused on work
when i'm at home i'm focused on those
three gorgeous babies you know
so it i i think that is a breakthrough
for folks to realize look it's i can't
do everything it's just
impossible yeah but but then it also
help gives you permission to be present
in what you are doing whether that's
work or home yeah
and what's interesting ken is when we
ask about balance which i i am asked
about this all the time
i think what we're really asking is
something else i think we're saying
how can i be proud of how i spend my
time how can i be happy in my life
how can i be confident in my choices
when i say yes to this thing or that
thing
and what's fascinating is when you
follow my steps to balance i lay out in
this book
you actually that is the result you are
happier you are more confident you are
more
fulfilled and you feel that sense of
balance but it wasn't because you
balanced everything perfectly like a
scale with trade-offs
it was because you learned to align your
time with what's right right now
and then be proud of those things and so
it's a different approach and i think it
actually solves the problem in a better
way
i was in a country store not too long
ago up in brevard north carolina
beautiful mountain community where my
in-laws had retired to and
you know it was one of those frou-frou
stores you know so it's like stacy's
going in so i have to
sure and so we're just walking around
and she's shopping and i'm just perusing
i saw a little sign on a shelf and i'll
never forget it and it said
you can do everything you want just not
at the same time
yep and you're in
i mean i want to ask you about seasons
yeah because
you know i know your journey right so i
know your story a little bit more than
probably the average person
being a colleague of yours but now
you're in it feels like you're in
several seasons at once but you're
getting ready to go back to
not getting ready you are moving back
into seminary which is a graduate level
program
while being a ramsey personality and
everything that comes with that a show
writing coaching you're a wife to matt
and then you're a mama to three awesome
kiddos
what would you say to men and women
right now that feel like
i'm straddling several seasons yeah
yeah i think i think when we take the
pressure off to do everything
then it gives us this reminder that you
have permission to do what's right right
now so as an example
what's right right now okay you gave
some examples there of like
work and my kids and seminary that's a
lot
but there are a lot of things that i
don't do yeah
and so because i don't have time for
those those are not a priority right
now when i let's say for example you
know my house isn't as clean as i want
which it never is
or i'm not working out as much as i want
which i am not in the season or seeing
my friends as much as i want
instead of feeling guilty for that i'm
like oh well that's just not right right
now let me give you another example i
would love to
play on an adult soccer league someday i
would love to travel to europe i would
love to do lots of things
and you could look at that go oh boohoo
poor me i'm never going to get to that
no no
just because something's not right right
now doesn't mean it's never right
it just means it's not right right now
this season gives you permission
to shake the guilt of all this pressure
and good things good opportunities
desires that you have
and say it doesn't mean it's never right
it's just not right right now so that
that is probably one of the most
powerful questions you can ask yourself
what's right right now do that
and watch how it gives you permission to
be present for that thing
and shake the guilt of all the things
that are not right right now by the way
if you are struggling with feeling out
of balance if you feel like
i don't know why i feel so busy all the
time i don't know why i feel out of
balance
i actually created a quiz to help you
get to the root of it i've identified
four main causes
of being out of balance and this quiz is
going to show you which
one you might struggle with and what to
do about it you can take my balance quiz
by texting busy to 33789
that's busy to 3 3 7 8 9
figure out why you feel out of balance
in the first place by the way that's
free so i don't know why anybody
wouldn't text
dizzy to 33789 right now and just see
where you stand and don't forget the new
book take back your time the guilt-free
guide to life balance
on pre-sale ramsey solutions.com
kristyright.com go get it right now
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings you get free samples
free shipping and with the new promo
codes they run every month you'll save
even more
use promo code ramsey to get the best
deal today's question comes from david
in texas
he writes in i'm 31 years old debt free
including my condo and
i have 65 000 in savings i currently
work for the government in
it i chose this path because as a
teenager i was painfully shy and didn't
like
interacting with people now i'm mature
personality has changed and i love
being with and helping people i'd like
to go back to school to be a nurse
which i can complete in less than three
years i can afford my living expenses
and the school cost with the savings i
have would you recommend
that i make this jump with a nursing
degree and i t background i could pivot
to health
informatics after a few years of
experience as a nurse
yes and it's not even a jump
way to go david this is the biggest
no-brainer
in the history of questions
all of the money situation is taken care
of your cash flowing there's no debt
here
it's clearly passion for you and
gives you a ladder by which you can
continue to advance
i wish i could add more to this question
but there's nothing there
it's a no-brainer and again not a jump
this is gonna be a really cocky stroll
you know like i mean he's got this i
like that and that by the way
that's what we want at ramsay solutions
we don't want you taking big jumps
financially or professionally
it's not necessary uh i think we we
romanticize this stuff from movies and
and stuff like this and some of these
social media uh
doofuses that are out there that are you
know posing next to private jets and
telling you
oh just go for it
maybe not maybe not you know what's
interesting though is i think that so
often people see it as a jump not
because the money's not there like in
david's case
but because it just feels scary yeah
sure oh it's just so scary because it's
new
put the plan on paper put them see how
you can afford this on paper and let the
information give you the confidence that
you are okay we get that
a similar call here on the ramsey show
often where
people are scared to do something scared
to buy something scared to change jobs
and they have the money it's just scary
because it's new it's not because you
can't afford it you absolutely can
and you should you should do it yeah i
love it all right let's go to joshua in
indianapolis hey joshua how are you
i'm doing great how are you all today
good how can can i help
my question is my wife and i are on uh
baby step two
we live in a 120 year old house it needs
a lot of renovations it's our starter
home we've been in it for about eight to
nine years uh we were considering
upgrading
all of our friends around to star we
have not because we were kind of on hold
we wanted to talk to you guys about what
would be the best thing to do
we owe twenty nine thousand dollars on
it uh we're real close to paying it off
but again it's gonna need a lot of
renovation once it's done so do we
pay it off um reno it maybe stay in it
maybe sell it now maybe upgrade now
what do you guys think i need some help
how much debt do you have total other
than the 29 that you own the house
we owe 12k on a car and that's all wow
okay when you say it needs tons of
renovations but you've lived in it for
eight or nine years what renovations are
you talking about
uh well we recently found some mold in
our bathroom
the home hasn't been updated in about 40
to 50 years we bought it as
is it's livable and we've enjoyed
staying there
but it's not really suiting our needs
anymore the kitchen needs redone
you know basically cosmetics but also
you know the electrical is going to need
replaced in the next five or six years i
had that looked at
um the roof is fine um but the
foundation's got some cracks in it
things like that how much though i think
christie asked the right question how
much
how much money is it going to cost to do
all of that
i would say 50 to 60 000. all right um
okay so what why are you thinking about
selling it y'all want to move anyway
because you said the house doesn't suit
your needs repairs aside you said it
doesn't
what does that mean yes repairs besides
we we're leaning towards moving anyway i
want to move you know because of the
amount of work my wife likes it but
she's also considering moving as well
okay how much clothes are dark how much
do you guys make
48 to 50k a year okay
other than the 29 000 that you owe in
the house and other than whatever
potential repairs let's ignore that for
just one second um
how long will it take you to pay off
this 12 000.
on the car oh year and a half at the
most is my plan
okay uh let me ask you this how much is
the house worth do you think if you put
it on the market today you got an idea
uh i would say 50 55.
and you got that much you got to put in
repairs in it well
yeah yeah so and
did you that's your and that's your uh
combined income is the 48 to 50 that's
both of you
yes that's combined interesting i'm a
little surprised the house is only worth
50. is it really run down
um we bought it for 39.99 it's an old
farmhouse and kind of the middle of
nowhere
um i have not had it appraised and
i essentially bought it so have you had
a have you had a real estate
professional which you could contact
at ramseysolutions.com come out and take
a look at it and give you a really good
idea what the market will bear i mean
how educated of a guest was that that
you gave me on 50 000
oh it's not a very good educated guess i
have not had someone out all right well
i think that's worth it do you
understand what i'm saying that you
really got to see what this thing is
worth you got any acreage
uh no sir just a half acre okay
yeah um i think you need some more
information
yeah um what i was going to say before
you said the mold what i was going to
say is
pay off your debt and then sell the
house you know i'm not opposed to you
moving and getting a new house that's
fine
you know upgrading your house a little
bit get definitely getting something
that's that's maybe newer better
whatever
you've got some money to be able to put
down on it but but you want to do that
debt-free you want to do that after baby
step two when you have three to six
months of emergency fund
for when things come up because they
will so that's kind of the
the baby step you've got a thousand
dollar emergency fund then you pay off
all your debt
baby step two then you save up three to
six months of expenses
and then you save to put a down payment
on a house now because you have
some equity in this house you could use
that when you sell it
the only concern that i have for you is
the mold situation
and so that may be something that would
that would kind of trump this where you
just need to get out and you maybe get
out
sell the house take the equity pay off
your debt and put something down
on something small or maybe it's
something where you
uh sell the house take that money pay
off your debt and then rent for a little
bit
until you save up some more than buy
something else that you want i think
that you
i think that you need to take care of of
your situation with the mold for sure
um but but like ken said let's go ahead
and get a real appraisal
let's figure out how much this is
actually worth um
i i think you do make the move and i
think when you do you pay off your debt
um maybe you move to another house maybe
you rent for a while
um but either way i think we need to get
out of that house because the the mold
is something you don't mess around with
but i i i would tell him i had to deal
with it we bought a house recently and
discovered it when doing some renovating
yeah
the the mold remediation is not as scary
and crazy as you think
usually i have no idea i don't want to
sound like you know uh mr house renault
guy i'm not
but christy's right that's a health
issue and if you're going to sell it
anyway let's say we decide to sell it
and rent which is one of the options you
gave him that mold's going to need to be
taken care of yeah
so take care of that first and uh and
then go from there
and run your options yeah but i think a
real estate agent can help you see how
much it's actually worth because that's
gonna be really really important yeah
to you making the best decision the
other thing ken i think is is
hard with some of these some of these
situations is we don't have all the
information we're trying to make a
decision
that's right right like whether it's
with a job someone called you know in
the last hour about like
well i think i want to be a tech for
this thing you're like well do you know
and when you have limited information
you're not going to make the best
decision
yes but the great news is the
information is out there yeah
if you do some of the work you and i
both talk about this all the time the
other thing that you need all the
information is it allows you to overcome
fear
there's a natural amount of fear
attached to any change or any new thing
but it it doesn't have to be you know
paralyzing fear when we have information
and you make a very good point
get all the facts and then it's not as
scary
as it needs to be i mean there's natural
fear going into anything new as you
touched on last segment
but my goodness uh to put the puzzle
together we need all the pieces yeah
yeah and ask multiple people if you're
getting quotes on mold remediation
get three quotes yeah not just one
person yeah you know whatever you're
doing do your homework yes it takes work
but it pays off in the long run
not only in a financial sense but also
in your peace of mind of knowing you did
your due diligence
and you're doing the best thing this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
according to the united states census
bureau nearly 1 in 10 people relocated
to a new city last year
and that was in 2020 that means this
year there's a good chance you or
someone you know is planning a big move
now i know it feels like there are a
thousand unknowns you're juggling when
you're relocating
but you cannot lose focus of one of the
most important personal
and financial factors in your move your
housing
i recommend hiring a quality real estate
agent like one of our endorsed local
providers or
elps to help you find the right home in
your new city
elps are top performing experts in their
local market
and have years of experience helping
folks just like you
make successful moves it's easy to get
instantly connected with an endorsed
local provider agent
just go to ramseysolutions.com agent
and talk with a ramsey trusted agent
about how they can help with your
relocation
that's ramseysolutions.com
agent i'm chrissy wright and ken coleman
and i are answering your calls triple
eight
eight two five five two two five we're
on for a couple more segments if you've
got a call
if you've got a question rather give us
a call all right we're gonna go to
john in san francisco california hey
john how are you
i'm good how are you guys good how can
can i help
all right i'll try and keep this short
um i'm 24. i live in san francisco with
a roommate making about
99k growth i recently got a job alter
from uh funds i worked in investing
for about 160 to 170 000
but a lot of that is through bonuses um
the catch is that it's a really far
coming away
and having a car in the city is insanely
expensive
so looking at the difference after taxes
taxes on the bonus you know the various
costs of having a car
for the first time and being a young man
it's just it comes out only to about 10k
net a year
and another wrinkle is just i'm not sure
it's that great for my career growth
uh you know it is a sort of more direct
investing
role but i i just don't know if this
sort of you know if a long commute is
worth it
so that's the real question i'm gonna
let ken answer this because i know he's
gonna
dig into this and ask you lots of great
questions i just want to call out from
the get-go john it sounds like you don't
want it
like you're making a strong case of why
you shouldn't take it so i just want to
call it sounds like you've
you're already leaning that way am i
right
well i'm really so this is the other
wrinkles i'm really well supported in my
current role i have a fantastic manager
she's really supportive she wrote to the
executive committee with sort of an
offer in my ask
to sort of match and keep me and keep me
to stay
john um john and john john john listen
this is so simple so i'm also guessing
the one thing you didn't say i'm gonna
take a guess i don't mind if i'm wrong
that your current job also really
represents a ladder for you
professionally
that there's opportunity for growth
there correct
um yeah it also will let me follow um
you know my girlfriend
she's going to law school next year it's
just it's just a much more flexible
working environment i could follow her
i can see myself moving yeah so that's
all that relational piece is all bonus
so here's the deal
i would say no and i think you called us
today for permission to say no
to a job offer that seems really really
awesome am i right
yeah yeah let me tell you why john and
and i want to help you feel really good
about this an
hour from now or three hours from now so
christy here's what i found
taking calls from people who have taken
promotions and six months later they
call me they go ken i took a really
great job
and i don't like it i said well why'd
you take it and they go
because the money was really good and
there's one like you have to that's it
but there's one other factor
when we get a job offer it's not just
the money
all right it's also we feel wanted and
everybody wants to feel wanted oh
they want me oh that feels good
and then the money makes it almost a
it is good it feels good to be wanted
and then the extra money makes you go
this is the
right decision and john i'm really
thankful that you called us
thanks for being vulnerable with us and
your gut is
absolutely right it's not worth it for
multiple reasons that you already laid
out this is a great decision for you
to say no say no to the good so that you
can say
yes to the best and i'm going to tell
you something folks
sometimes promotions become traps
i've heard it over and over again you've
got to
step back and say all right because
here's what i teach christy
it's never the money it better be
the next rung on the professional ladder
it better be about purpose because i'm
going to tell you something
more dollar signs but less significance
uh always leads to somebody going man i
boy this was the wrong move so good on
you sir
say no and here's the problem chris we
talked about this before
when you gave great advice to somebody
and i said they're gonna question
people are going to go you're crazy to
turn this down no
john you're not for all the reasons that
you've already determined that you
already knew before you called us the
other thing i want to call out is this
is not the only
opportunity you'll ever have correct
you're good and you're going to continue
to grow
and expand your skills and be in high
demand
and there may be another job that offers
you the same amount of money or more
that is closer next to your girlfriend
all the things
this is not the when we make decisions
based on fear and scarcity
they're also always bad decisions and so
we don't we don't want to make decisions
based on that this is not the only good
opportunity
you had your mind made up before you
called us but i'm glad that we could
confirm it yeah for you
all right let's go to cody in lancaster
pennsylvania hey cody how are you
cody you there all right all right
no cody well you know ken the thing that
is interesting to me about this last
call about john
and his current company is and you made
this such a good point when we see
dollar signs we stop
thinking clearly we think that that's
the next thing that we have
to do i feel so good about it people are
going to tell you you're crazy yeah
people are going to tell you you're
crazy
for not taking the money and here's the
other thing you're going to end up in
that spot but then your old position may
be gone
you took the position you're calling the
king coleman show miserable
i thought i was supposed to take it i
think there's also this pressure that
like
you have to or you're missing out you
have to or you'll never
be asked again you have to or it's the
only job out there you're absolutely
right and it's just not true
it's not true and i will tell you
there's so much
fear of peers what are other people
going to say
if i don't take this and that we cannot
underestimate that when we're alone with
our thoughts
um it's okay to feel that because you
love these people
they speak into your life but the other
day you gotta go they're not the ones
that are gonna follow this path
they can give me advice all they want to
they can give me perspective all they
want to
but it's my path it's not their path and
i
i tell you you know because of the
business that you and i are in i mean
you and i really are in the business of
helping people reach their dreams i mean
really and i got to tell you i have seen
more and more and more
that the friends and family members who
poopoo
the pursuit of the dream many times are
doing it because they don't want to be
left behind themselves
it's that insecurity they're projecting
they didn't that's interesting
they didn't chase their own and when
they see you go it's like it's not that
they want to hold you back it's not that
they have ill will
sure because i dug into that i was like
how could the people that that love us
the most
discouraged the most sure it's their own
fear and you just nailed it it's
projection
because they go i didn't chase it
i don't want you leaving me in the
middle of the road
while you're moving forward or i chased
it i chased it and i
didn't work whatever happened right and
so we've got to be careful to say
do i believe this is right yeah
do i believe it's right i mean you're
talking about earlier do the right thing
and the right thing is hey
what's the next rung on the ladder for
me mm-hmm
yeah regardless of what anybody
long-term thinking long-term
not immediate paycheck but long-term
what is right is this going to move me
in the direction i want to be is this
the location i want to be is this
aligned with my goals of where i want to
be you coach business owners all the
time on the small business owners like
what's the right move you know there's a
temptation there to grow too quick or to
take a big risk
well and i tell people this with
anything in life whether it's in
business
and how you manage your time in a career
move
if you don't begin with the end in mind
you'll end up crossing someone else's
finish line
and you have got to start with your
vision i believe she just dropped a mic
folks i think that's what they're doing
someone tweet that stitch it on a pillow
is that what they call it you dropped a
mic
drop your headset please as you take us
to break that was really good say it one
more time
if you don't begin with the end in mind
you will end up crossing
someone else's finish line and and we're
out this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
the words of the mouth are deep waters
but the fountain of wisdom is a rushing
stream
proverbs 18 4. what you do has greater
impact than what you say
stephen covey said that that's a good
one it's like parenting
do as i say not as i do oh isn't that
the truth
all right ken coleman and i are
answering your calls today this has been
a great friday and cody is back with us
from lancaster
pennsylvania hey cody how are you
i'm doing good how about yourself good
how can ken and i help today
okay so i'm 26 years old i just started
on the baby steps with babysit 3.
i have a full-time job make about 40 000
a year plus over time
um and then i also volunteer at our
local ems agency about 2 000
hours a year cool so i'm wondering how
do i balance
that volunteering stuff which i love and
have a lot of fun time
or fun you know doing with maybe picking
up a second job
and building you know increasing that
intel and increasing what
your income the income yeah yeah so
you're in did you say baby step three
yes okay well first of all cody you're
doing great
to be 26 years old and debt-free
and working on your three to six months
emergency fund you're
starting to get into the this the part
of the baby steps
that are a little less intense and that
doesn't mean we're not intentional
right we're definitely intentional but
there's not this like
uh gazelle intensity where you have to
go as hard and fast as you can
to get through four five and six yes you
want to get your your emergency fund
funded but it's not this sense of
urgency how much do you have in savings
right now
um right now i have about 1500 in my
emergency fund
okay so you want to build that up what
would three to six months be for you
um i'm looking at starting around 10 000
for now
okay 10 000 just to you know give give a
little extra cushion
yeah and what do you make a year uh
about 40 000.
okay cool well plus overtime so sure
well you're doing great i'm gonna i'm
gonna suggest you do something super
tactical and i literally i talk about
this in my book
on balance and that is for you to sit
down and do an exercise where you write
out
what are your most important priorities
now this sounds like a simple task
cody it can be really hard it can be
really hard to say okay
in this season this season being baby
step three this season being 26 years
old this season making 40 000 a year all
the things that kind of define the
parameters of this season in your life
i want you to write down what is most
important one two three four five in
order
now it doesn't mean on any given week
that can't change or any given day that
can't change
but what it's gonna force you to do is
it's gonna force you to decide
which is more important to you right now
getting your income up getting through
baby step number three with only 1500
i would say that that probably should be
at the top but it doesn't mean you can't
volunteer it might just mean you
volunteer
i don't know 200 hours this year instead
of 2 000.
and then when you get your emergency
fund you're able to ramp that back up so
it just
it forces you to put into a hierarchy
what is most important what is second
most important third most important so
on obviously your full-time job is going
to be your primary source of income
from a financial sense that's your most
important second
getting this these um these hours you
know these hours in the overtime and so
on to be able to get your income up
and then third volunteer after that but
if we try to treat everything as if it's
created equal
then when push comes to shove we don't
know how to make decisions
and we don't make any traction and so
you have permission to focus on what's
most important to you you just need to
decide what that is
and it was just like ken and i were
talking about earlier
if you were listening to the show
earlier just because something's not
right right now
doesn't mean it's not ever right maybe
next year
you work 2 000 hours and and from there
you're able to keep that volunteer up
so it's just it's just focusing on the
right thing at the right time and when
you focus on the right thing
at the right time you're not only going
to be feel balanced
you're also going to make progress on
your finances this is what we love
helping people do
through the baby steps here at ramsey
solutions so if you do that write out
your list and then it will remind you
hey
what's most important right now let's
get my income up just like you said
getting that emergency fund up and maybe
when you get your emergency fund to
six thousand dollars you ramp up your
hours volunteering
and then they go up to 500 then they go
up to a thousand it can be a gradual
increase of hours it doesn't have to be
your whole emergency fund
is funded fully before you get to
volunteer to the level that you'd want
to it can be a gradual turning on the
faucet
as we say a lot of times but it just
helps you remember what's most important
right now so you don't get distracted
yeah you know and i would just encourage
you cody chrissy's absolutely right
uh remember why you volunteer uh you
know focus on
on the the why and and
what result you're after and why you
show up and don't get hung up on well i
sure would like to volunteer
this many hours and i'm not getting to
don't focus on that i would just do a
little shift and say
this is awesome that i'm even in a
financial position in a life position to
where i can do this
and remind yourself what the heart is in
the volunteering for
and then i think you're going to just be
so full of gratitude that you're really
not going to be thinking anymore about
well i sure would like to do more hours
and i think if you do that you're going
to be fine and
again i just want to echo what christy
said you're off to a great start
in life you've got a wonderful path
ahead of you i love your heart i think
there's going to be some wonderful
things that come out of this
and the other thing i would tell you is
that as you're volunteering
and you're spending time with this
organization pay attention be a human
sponge get that antenna up and pay
attention for what
might be uh future opportunities for you
because there's clearly some mission
involved in this volunteering as it
always is so good on you you're a
fantastic young man
thanks for the call you know ken when i
was a young life leader
years ago i was a young life leader from
2006
to 2012 i think and i was a leader in
high school i mean in college as well
but what's interesting is when i felt
started to feel this tension
where i was showing up to clubs and
showing up to leader meetings and it
felt like
this was not right for me anymore that
was hard yeah because
your heart was so in it it was and it
was also it started to feel like well
because this used to be right it should
always be right
and i think sometimes when our season
changes whether it changes because of
family
whether it changes because of our
priorities whether it changes because of
financial reasons like we're trying to
pay off our debt
that can be hard to let go of what was
and accept this new thing that is now
what is right right now and so i just
want to encourage
cody but anybody listening if you're in
that that
place where you're transitioning between
seasons you're like but i used to always
do this
i used to always spend time on this this
used to be my priority and and i
always love to do this it's okay if that
changes you have permission to change
your mind
change your plans change your priorities
you should and
and what i what i see a lot in people
that i work with ken and i've been
guilty of this myself but our season
changes
and we don't change with it we don't
adapt to it we don't acknowledge the new
season that we're in
so so uh you know i think back to when i
had carter my
my oldest child when he was a newborn i
still expected that i would do all the
things i used to do before kids
and then i couldn't i was exhausted the
house was a mess if i got a
shower once a week it was a so i felt
like a failure right because
my new season was not like what i
expected and so if if you're in that
place right now
and let's say you've decided to start
your debt-free journey
you're working the baby steps you used
to do all these things or spend money on
these things or go out with friends out
to dinner
go on date night go on vacation you're
not doing them it doesn't
mean you'll never get to do that again
no that's
that's actually why we teach what we
teach is so that you can do that
debt-free
yeah but you have permission to change
your priorities when you're in the new
season
yeah you just you just really made me
start to think i think that's such a
good word
and i'm i'm looking at my own life and
seasons that i look back and instead of
with the regret i need to look back and
reminisce
well you know what we do we look at
times where hey stacy and i eventually
will be empty nesters again yeah but
there was a time where we did things you
know you
one of my favorite christie wright
stories is you being single
and deciding to go live on a farm and
have all the animals the fainting goat
is the all-time legendary story
uh we'll say that for another time
because it really is fantastic
and you could look back on that and go
well i don't have all the freedom i used
to instead of regretting that
reminiscing that was a wonderful season
you learned so much about yourself that
make you the wife and mom you are today
we need to look back with fond
reminiscing not
fateful regret well that and it's
interesting too because sometimes we can
have the opposite problem where we look
back on our past
as if it was so good like oh my gosh i
wish i had the freedom of before
and in our present we focus on the pain
oh my gosh little kids are so hard
there's peanut butter on my walls
focus on the good in both focus on the
good in your past and in your present
man my kids snuggle my neck like i know
they won't when they're
walking in the house today and they
squeeze mama's neck yes
focus on the good focus on the good in
your past the good in your present
and the good that i know god has for you
in your future
that's a good word to end on i want to
thank producer ben hill
associate producer kelly daniel and my
co-host and good friend ken coleman
fun this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show
did you know over 18 million people
listen to the ramsay show every week
and a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country
to find a station near you head to
thermsyshow.com
[Music]
you